[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible brilliant fun funny warm
interesting comedy loving science
explaining
Universe explaining Neil deGrasse Tyson
this is a mind-blowing conversation he
was eloquent interesting on everything
blew my mind four five six seven eight
twelve times made me question things
made me look at things differently got
me excited about the cosmos got me
thinking about food differently I don't
know why I'm telling you all this I'm
just so excited that you're here and
that you're going to listen in fact
here's a little taste of where our
conversation goes so when I tell people
about the universe
there's all kinds of stuff I'm not
telling you because it's boring as
okay
oh so no so I pre-edited it that's all
I'm excited for you guys to hear the
whole episode only a couple things to
plug up top a top one obviously is
Neil's book Neil my my dear friend Neil
uh Mr deGrasse Tyson however I can most
honorably discuss him Starry Messenger
Cosmic perspectives on civilization
that's what it's called by Neil deGrasse
Tyson that must be the most honorable
way Neil deGrasse Tyson Starry Messenger
Cosmic perspectives on civilization is
available now if you'd like to see me do
standing up comedy I'm currently on tour
go to pethomes.com or if you're going to
be in Los Angeles go to
largo-la.com I do a monthly show there
great but petehomes.com I'm going all
over the country hopefully you can come
to one of those shows thank you to
everybody that came out in Houston it
was incredible and if you want to
support this show why not try a pizza
pick Pizza pick art ads four things that
I actually use and actually love like
the perfect Jean as you know I hate hard
pants I don't know why it's the 21st
century and we're not wearing
comfortable soft pants that actually
look good we'll enter the perfect gene
they look great they feel incredible
they're stylish enough to to wear to
premieres and fancy Hollywood parties
but they're also comfortable enough to
take a nap in
that's just bags I got tired of wearing
yoga pants in public I can't pull it off
because I'm not sting or Phil Collins
but I don't like trapping my body like
it owes me money these are four real for
real the best looking pants and the best
feeling pans I've ever owned I have five
or six pair I have them in Gray I have
them in dark blue I have them in blue I
love these pants I never never ever take
them off they're two percent spandex 2.5
rayon but nobody needs to know nobody
will know they just look and feel
incredible they're super soft super
durable I've never had to replace them
regular jeans always tear in the crotch
and wear down and they're not khakis
your khakis and spare your nuts
liberate your lower limbs with the one
and only perfect Jean take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's j-e-a-n I
know this is a science episode it's not
Gene like genome
www.theperfectgene.nyc and use code
weirdo for 25 five percent off that
means you can get a pair for just 60
bucks show support for your body show
support for the show the perfect Gene
doc NYC and use code weirdo at checkout
alright everybody let's get in to Neil
deGrasse Dyson hey dude what's up man
what a pleasure don't change your eyes I
just want to talk to the cosmos that
actually I became Spirit energy in the
last time
I knew it you've always been a hiccup
away yeah it's got to feel great right
here I go here let me get this there it
goes oh there you are that's yeah I'm
gonna say it that's better that's better
or or I mean no because I got my I got
no no let's I mean we got
I mean we can we we can do
oh a blend a blend
what is it there's a there's a Chinese
art called Lee have you heard of Lee no
I haven't yeah I think you're gonna love
it I'm opening first of all what a
pleasure I I'm honored to meet you and
thank you for taking the time I almost
yeah I don't know if you know but I'm a
huge fan of stand-up comedy I didn't
know yeah it's just huge from way back I
think you guys hold
the the soul of civilization in the palm
of your hand and you reveal it to us
sometimes it's uncomfortable sometimes
it's enlightening but somebody has to do
it and no one else can do it I love you
guys are some of the smartest people
because you have to know everything and
then figure out how to make it funny no
deeper than everybody else does right so
I I love that and you know why I can
agree is because taking myself out of it
that's where I I go to Comedy for that I
I get served by comedy for that same
thing you know what I mean you must love
that like other other scientists other
astrophysicists minister to you you know
you can appreciate it and go like this
is great so that's yeah personally I
think the universe is hilarious but
other than that dude it is I'm going to
tell you something okay I I wrote down
Lee because I do want to tell you what
Lee is but the example I've been using
lately is I was dropping my daughter's
four
and we're rocked by the way if I seem a
little off it's just she was up all
night she's got a cop it's rough but I'm
gonna everyone knows absence of sleep
better than new parents that's it there
is no oh I studied hard in school and I
pulled all-nighters yeah you have no
idea you don't know you don't know it
was still you deciding when to break and
when you know what I mean like I'm my
rhythms are completely disrupted by this
and the noise that she makes as you know
as a parent is hardwired to me like it's
the sound that I my cortisol my stress
just goes it's what it's supposed this
is the din of all other noises of life
and it lands right in your that's right
and I must respond I go into like I
wouldn't say it's like absolute panic
but I can't not that I would but I can't
ignore it even if I wanted to even if I
was like her mom's got it she'll do this
one I'll do it but we've been up all all
night it's been just think about it
evolutionarily if they have had if when
they were in distress yes they had a
soft soothing voice no one would hear it
and they would just die and die a gene
pool with them gone goodbye all the
quiet lineages have been removed they've
been called from the herd okay you've
already stepped into premise that I go
cool is quiet think of Denzel Washington
right that's all my go-to example of
cool he's quiet he's like that's you
that's you he's very quiet and then
think of uncool it's like hey you guys
it's like it's like a dork and suspense
it's Urkel it's Urkel being like Oh God
need cheese a young Urkel yeah
Julia white not Julia Julia's had a nice
reconnaissance he's driving a Porsche
you know he's got he became Stefan or
Kell in real life he's doing it he's
doing great but I was thinking about
evolutionarily quiet doesn't give away
your position to Predators it doesn't it
also people competing for your food
source wolves are quiet wolves are cool
stealthy stealthy stealth is cool and
like think of an awkward boy at a at a
dance he's like hey ladies you know like
that is it speaks to like I was very
Jerry Lewis of you right there hey lady
waiting that and think of a cool guy
he's he's swamp this is why so the real
question is wait so the question is yes
how long can you stay with an annoying
voice
protected by your parents yes until you
get eaten by the lion right yes that's
right that that's the other that's uh
the classic Milhouse my mom thinks I'm
cool it's like yeah they're they're here
keeping you alive you need to be cool
outside of them like that this is the
the argument for co-sleep by the way
again we have a four-year-old so we've
been just sleeping letting her sleep in
our bed I read this book it's called
tribe it's a great book and he's he kind
of very subtly makes the argument that a
baby like Genetically speaking knows
it's uh vulnerable when it's alone and
in the dark it's like you can't be like
we live in a house you are in part of
the house it's just like I'm in the dark
and I can't touch the thing the Giants
that I summoned to get me food and
protection so he kind of without being
too preachy about it I know that's a
personal choice for parents it made it
really make sense I was like if the baby
wants in our bed she can be in our bed I
don't care even if I don't sleep and and
not to sound like old father time here
but
when she gets bigger of course there's
less room for you yes and you'll get
systematically more and more annoyed by
it however yes however you have to think
differently about it
there will be a day
that's the last day she ever climbs into
bed that's right that will go unheralded
yep not even remember that day in the
same way yes if it hasn't already
happened you're young enough so it
probably hasn't happened yet there's a
day it's the last day you will ever pick
up your child yeah I no one will
announce that I know here's the day nope
it'll just it just happened it's just
another time you picked her up and God
help you if you were like Ugh and like
you that was the last one and you didn't
even enjoy it the last one and you
didn't even know to enjoy it so there's
a lot of little things I don't mean to
sound like Father no old-timer parent
here but yeah this is it we think about
I I take comfort in the face did we
begin your podcast yeah we've begun
we're recording if that's okay it's cool
it's stealth I can't be like welcome to
the show you guys it's like I just oh
yeah we're just talking we're just two
guys talking it's fun let me tell you
first of all I was gonna say I still
pick my wife up so I'm confident as a
big bigger guy there I will always be
able to pick up my daughter I think I
think there's a there's no no no no you
don't understand no no no no that's not
how it works yeah okay I have to explain
are you ready okay okay
all right
you are a parent
your daughter is four years old yeah
every year that goes by
he gets
older and bigger and you get older and
weaker
so I'm not factoring in my weakness
okay and there's a point where those two
lines cross yes that's what it is yes
he's too heavy to pick up your too weak
to pick her up yeah you can say people I
thought you wanted
ends
I can still pick up my wife yeah that's
not gonna go too long either that's
right that's right uh what is the
scientific term for that I had a
confirmation bicycle or just a blind
spot it was just a blind spot it was a
bias it was definitely a bias
because it served my ego it it flattered
me it's a does that make it more of a
personal bias would you call it a
personal bias uh it's an ego bias an ego
bias an ego based bias yeah okay uh
going back to my daughter she's four
this is to your point about comedians we
drop and about how the universe is
hilarious and about how the universe
doesn't really care about us which I I
think is very very funny Seinfeld had a
bit about how the ocean just wants to
throw us out of it and and that's like
the joke it's like we keep trying to get
back in and it's just all it does is
heave us out of it even if you go in the
ocean and die it still sends you back to
the shore you're not staying of course
yeah nice try nice try you're still
getting ejected this is a human free
zone uh so I drop I'm gonna people on
the plot have already heard me tell the
story probably three times but I I
dropped my daughter off she's a little
shy I go in the circle with her and I
sit and they're singing a song about
monkeys falling in the water and an
alligator eating the monkeys basically
it's like a learning how to count song
what
yeah I know this is the morning song on
the carpet a lot of a lot of these kids
a lot of these kids songs are very
Bambi's mom well maybe they're maybe
they're they're more real like the
European folk tales I mean uh yeah uh
nursery rhymes uh before they got Disney
fight right that's right terrible oh my
God you read like an old German fairy
tale they all end with kids in a pie
it's all yeah yeah they get eaten yeah
Hansel and Gretel are dead and eat the
moral is you're gonna be a pie that's
that little red light Riding Hood was
eaten all right
Goldilocks was eaten Little Red Riding
Hood was eaten by a wolf that already
ate her grandmother so even if she got
away Granny's still dead and we have a
crust I can you say cry a uh a gender
bending I don't know a wolf in a
Granny's clothing yes that's species
both transvestite all that word is not
as common today I'm not sure well I'm
trying to keep us in the clear it you
know what we're saying everyone knows
the intent of what we're saying right
here's
there you go again I'm not even and I
don't I don't read the updates but um
it's a daily update you have to you have
to get with it well it's by the minute
yeah it might be by the minute we'll set
a new standard we're saying it's okay
for this conversation
um the song is something like ten little
monkeys swinging in a tree saying hey
alligator you can't catch me then they
fall and all you say to signify the
death is you go snap nine Little Monkeys
right so you don't say anything what
happened with the monkeys just rolling
out of bed that was a counting song that
was another one
and one said roll over roll over that's
different that's they all rolled that's
that's Bears over him one fell out and
Bane in the bed and the little one said
roll over yes that's just falling out of
bed well the monkey's one is alligator
and then the doctor said no more monkeys
jumping on the bed the Bears are laying
in the bed monkeys are jumping on the
bed alligators are eating the monkeys
that are falling out of the tree so this
is definitely the German fairy tale
version of the other two okay so at the
end of the song all the money it goes no
more monkeys in the tree one of the kids
goes what happened to the monkeys uh
another kid goes they swam away another
kid goes they ran away and then Dean
this little boy who I love he's one of
Lila's friends goes they died and the
teacher's like oh and then Dean goes
blood in the water oh he yells out blood
in the water it tell me what that means
isn't that comedy isn't that kind of one
of the roles of Comedy is to go like
checking out his his timing there and uh
well it's also you were saying that we
go to comedians to like get what we
don't get other places and I see in the
world a lot of like the monkeys ran away
and sometimes I go to Comedy to be like
no this is crazy we're vulnerable tulips
in a field we're in space ready to be
trembled right exactly we don't know
what's going on is is that what you
meant when you said that well no I meant
but more specifically their okay monkey
blood in the water that's sort of a
perceptive uh a morbidly comedic
observation of a preschooler but what I
would say is
comedians have the power
it's a it's a superpower really to
take
to observe what I take for granted and
show it back to me in a way I can laugh
at it so so of course you can do other
things as well but I think that's the
most enduring and endearing form of
Comedy because now I'm I'm a participant
with you it's not just your story I'll
tell you what happened I was on an
airplane going no it's here's something
that happens to all of us I agree okay
I'll give an example I was listening to
to
um a fellow who's always safe for work
um on the channel uh Jim Gaffigan okay
yeah yeah yeah so not a curse word ever
comes out of him but he makes an
observation right now I just never
thought of it it was you know we eat so
much I'm paraphrasing here but I'll get
the punchline we eat so much in America
and just think about it you know you go
to we have fast food restaurants and in
one of them you ordered
Fried Chicken
and it comes in a bucket
you're eating food out of a buck and I
thought damn you're right how come I
never saw it that's right it's served to
you in a bucket in a bucket because
that's what we're on a platter yeah not
in a little tasty cup yeah we're a few
Generations away from the buck uh the
wheelbarrow of fried chicken it's gonna
happen it's absolutely he also has an
observation that that hits all of us yes
so simple and safer the workplace and uh
and right there it was right in front of
our face right and and don't let me
Force this but I feel that science
serves a similar function one of one of
the frustrations of my life it's not
really a big frustration is that we're
not talking about what's going on like
there's I used to have a joke it never
really worked but I talked about how
space is boring to most people because
you can't eat it or have sex with it and
and the punch
you're welcome I'm laughing I'm laughing
I mean if I was performing for you and
your peers maybe because then I go I
think NASA made the rumor that the moon
is made of cheese to like Peak Interest
it was like it was to get funding
because people are like we're going to
the Moon who cares it's made of cheese
godspeed that was the joke like bring
crackers bring back some breakfast but
like does that I mean you were 15 when
you started giving lectures lecture was
at 15 yeah I just turned 15. were you in
that same place of like why aren't we
talking about that's how I feel about
chicken buckets that's how I feel about
everything like oh so what I did was no
excellent question and perceptive so I
made it a life's Quest
to judge what about the universe would
be more interesting to you
what what parts of the universe are more
interesting to you than other parts I
don't mean literal Parts but what ideas
what concepts what objects what words
what things you know as comedians some
words are funnier than others just
because of how they're pronounced or how
they're spelled because they're comprise
them yeah so I've done this sifting
throughout my life and what my
colleagues on the other hand have been
doing is what is the full curriculum we
want to teach you so that you learn what
you need to in astrophysics and instead
when I was outside of the pure academic
environment I said what can I tell you
that you will never forget yeah remember
forever and will spark an interest so
that you'll then become a lifelong
learner so I viewed myself as someone
who can light a flame within you rather
than to teach you an entire
um recipe and you know I got this one
very simple I got it from Father Guido
Sarducci okay
no no
you're a comedian you know Father Guido
Sarducci
[Laughter]
yeah I understand okay so his his stick
was he was dressed as a Catholic priest
which I thought got old very quickly
because I don't like too much stick in a
comedy routine but what has lasted with
me ever since I saw it it was a routine
and it used to show up on Saturday Night
Live in the 70s all right so here's the
routine he said and he speaks with an
Italian accent like he just walked out
of the Vatican all right any and he's
smoking okay and so he said I have a I
have a I want to start a new University
it's all what kind of universe is a
straight man what kind of oh it's a five
minute degree
what do you mean in five minutes so you
just go to university for five minutes
and you get your degree how does that
work what do you no no
I only teach you
what you remember 10 years later oh my
God
no he says so economics okay so what's
your economic class
supply and demand
buy it sell it for more that's all you
need to know wow that's all you'll
remember 10 years later yeah okay and
then he said well how about Spanish
class right here it is
[Laughter]
so this was very deep to me because I
thought to myself
why am I teaching you all the sticks
because I spent years teaching
University why am I spending this time
you're not going to remember it a week
after the final exam much less a year
five years ten years so why don't I
shape the content to be the most
mind-blowing stuff that you will
remember 10 years later and the total
amount you'll remember will then be more
yeah yeah yeah that's my exercise I love
that what I do so when I tell people
about the universe
there's all kinds of stuff I'm not
telling you because it's boring as
okay
no
so I pre
that's all yeah
it's interesting I wonder if the
comparison could be like you get people
interested in I'm not putting down
Taylor Swift but pop music stuff that
like it has hooks we get it and if you
started your paragraph by saying I'm not
putting down Taylor Smith you're putting
down yeah yeah it seems like that it
sure seems that way but I could have
picked anybody uh Billy eilish you're
you're taking what I what I mean is pop
music is doing the same thing we take
all of the complexity of music as a
category and we're saying what what pop
means popular which I think is so funny
we're gonna release some popular music I
mean it's like trying to make a viral
video but if you get people interested
in music maybe later they'll listen to
Beethoven's sixth or whatever I don't
know that that's their motive because it
is my motive
interested in the field so that you'll
buy books you'll watch videos
documentaries right uh go to people's
YouTube science channels so that I've
spark an interest I don't know that pops
stars are saying let me make a popist
music so that you'll then go buy
Beethoven I don't think that's what's
motivating but it might happen it might
be a happy accident
yeah yeah I I I've heard the argument
that that University is to teach you how
to learn not what you learn ideally it
should be if you if a good education is
how to learn so that not to get all
commencement address on you because
that's a good one in a few weeks but
let's do a rough draft you can have my
moon made of cheese uh you can't eat it
or have sex with it that's your opener
can I do that yeah yeah of course I I
flatter myself you'll have something
better don't worry so of course the word
commencement means beginning not end and
people see it all my school's over and I
joke about this you know Alice Cooper's
one of his famous anthems was I forgot
the title of the song but the refrain
schools out for the summer yeah yeah
rules out forever yeah this is a an
Anthem that celebrates that you no
longer have to learn yeah yeah just
pause and reflect on that for a moment
your only job for five hours a day what
is that right that yeah is to learn and
now you cast your papers in the air as
you run down the steps celebrating this
and I say that burden has been relieved
yes you have you'll spend so many more
years not in school than in school that
if you view learning as a chore then you
become ossified in that moment thinking
that all that you have have learned is
all you need to know for the rest of
your life and then you become somebody
who can't relate to new ideas right new
thoughts right discoveries and we'll
never know the intoxication I mean
you've talked about spiritual encounters
with the universe these are intellectual
things that have touched you that stir
you but now we're both father time I
figured out most of the learning I've
done happened after school because I
figured out oh my God can I I'm gonna
give you my analogy I want to see if you
relate to this I was like it's
shoplifting it's thrilling you go into
someone else's I go into Neil deGrasse
Tyson's master class or or the series is
that you do I can steal the facts that
you sweat it over and I'd like that it's
shoplifting it's shoplifting well
nobody's looking right and nobody's
looking and you know when when I was
single I would be like would help you
meet people it would you'd meet you'd be
more interesting like their sweat is
your game like you go out and be like I
don't know if you know this but Europa
is is expanding and Contracting like a
Racquetball and there might be an ocean
of water and everyone's like yeah that's
very good I did nothing nothing but
listen all I did was listening
yeah
and he work with the racquetball that
was good that was not wrong it's not
that it's expanding if you're correcting
oh it's not excuse me it's deforming its
shape and then reshaping oh it's
deforming
plus
I had a Europa question for you what the
analogy to the racquetball is correct
the record was not expanding and
Contracting it's getting deformed every
time you hit it and it bounces back to
shape that pumps extension and
contraction be different from deformity
and
expansion you take the whole sphere and
expand it I see contract it this is
Photoshop it's become misshapen yes it
restores its shape we're command T we're
doing a free transform instead yeah okay
photoshopped for the win would you eat a
fish from the oceans of Europa we've we
found one we brought it back to Earth
would you eat it well so here's a really
crazy thought
than you imagined okay this is called a
day off for a podcast please I love this
all right you ready I don't know if
you're ready are you seeing it yes you
are I am seated yes for those who are
listening I see them on video he's
seated I am seated
so you it turns out
that the organic molecules that comprise
life
okay have a certain handedness to them
so I just it's you might have remembered
this from chemistry to something called
the chirality of a molecule so you can
have molecules like water H2O
if you look at the water molecule in a
mirror
it's exactly what it looks like in real
life
okay okay but there's some molecules in
a mirror
are not the same molecule
it's not that the atoms are swapped it's
just that in in your life it twists a
certain way and in the mirror it twists
the other way
no if you write down the molecule that
the molecular form is the same but if
you construct the molecule it's
different in a mirror than in real life
you say well who cares I'll tell you why
there's a molecule I don't know what the
whole molecule is called but the
molecule that gives you the flavor of
mint hmm
it's the same molecular formula but
different in America it's an isomer of
the molecule that gives you the flavor
of Caraway
what yes
okay so cat so do you take this molecule
reassemble it twisting the other way and
it intersects your taste buds in a
different configuration giving you the
flavor of Caraway instead of mint I
think spearmint okay wow wow it could be
peppermint one of the two mints so so
they're different so now here's my point
that's just the lead-in to what I'm
telling you yes okay
there's
um now I'll give you a mid one this this
you could probably tap this for some
serious jokes PepsiCo
developed an an oil
that had a chirality that your digestive
tract
does not
see or digest because it does not
interact intersect with the molecule
because of the handedness because the
handedness they can't bond with it yeah
yet the texture still felt like you were
having oil so rather than baked
chips
potato chips because no one likes those
really right I mean the end of the day
it's a concession correct yeah um
radical concession a concession
they would fry them in this oil that you
could not digest right
so you get the sensation of the oil but
then if you read the warnings on the
back of the package yes uh may cause
anal leakage I remember this this is
this is olestra right you know Lester
you remember leakage oil that was it
goes through you it's not your body says
I don't know what this is yes I can't
interact with okay so now here's my
point I have to I have to interrupt
you're going to love it Ray Romano had a
bit about this it's on his live at
Carnegie Hall record it's his closer he
goes that's that's the only anal leakage
that's the only label that the cigarette
company is like we're not that
nobody's leaking over here oh so now hit
your point I'm so sorry I know that
concert it's fun I like the beginning
where he says hey look I'm at Carnegie
Hall you know he says yeah yeah you know
the teachers who complained about him
making jokes in class yes and he said I
I wanted to invite every woman that ever
turned me down but we would have had to
put in a second balcony which is which
is just a great he's so funny I love
that by the way I I am in a movie with
him no way way
wait and I'll tell you about it in a
minute let me finish this yeah finish
your point you asked me a fish on Europa
I won it fish on Europa so it turns out
all life on Earth
the the amino acids that make up our
proteins have the same handedness yes
all life on Earth that's part of why we
know we're one Genesis because there's
nothing in principle that wouldn't
prevented an entire other Genesis of
life
coexisting with us that has a different
handedness that's interesting because
the theory that mushrooms came from an
asteroid or something Have you ever
heard that that there's something
otherworldly unique about no no no
that's no that's not I don't know where
you heard that
these are the rumors we're hearing
outside of class
you want to be a lifelong learner you
want to be a lifelong learner of the
right stuff yeah that's right that's
right well look you just corrected it
I've been going around thinking that
mushrooms were like we good with
mushrooms okay we're good uh so last I
checked there's some adjustment I maybe
I missed it okay okay please keep going
so here's the point yes the every other
than Salt
uh and two other food group Foods uh
milk and honey which is very biblical by
the way yeah salt milk and honey
everything we
consume for calories
and otherwise nourishment was once alive
every human being lives off the death of
some other life form from the Tree of
Life okay that's right the only
exceptions are milk and honey which
don't require killing that's insane I
never put that together that Moses is
trying to go to the promised land the
land of milk and honey these would be
the foods that are non-dual they're not
life living eating death yeah I don't
know how much the Bible thought about
that in advance of writing it but it is
these two Foods what's interesting of
course is veganism
is expressly excludes milk and honey
that's right from their diet interesting
even though they're perfectly happy
because I say in my book I have a whole
chapter on vegetarianism and the
meterians and vegetarians I'll tell you
about that in just a minute but I'll
write it down Europa fish okay yeah a
number three deep in the thing I know
welcome to the show okay so but my only
point is
we
because we have to eat other living
things
for our sustenance
if the fish is a full life form but has
the opposite
chirality yeah of life on Earth
I can eat it and Gain No No nourishment
from it wow it's a lustra yeah it's a
lustra in a fully formed life form so
you're saying if you eat a fish from the
Moon Europa you're gonna get anal
leakage on this planet like most likely
pull out the entire it just comes out
fine it go out the bones it swam through
you it fired went through the ocean of
Neil
exactly so the interesting thing mate
maybe we did have two Genesis of life on
Earth but and they tried to eat each
other but one sort of won out a little
bit it ate more of itself than of the
other and then one just I mean we can
speculate here but it's a fascinating
fact the first two the first two things
eating each other I mean that's if you
you eat only your own chirality you will
survive if you eat the other chirally
you have no nourishment from it and
you'll die
so it had to have eaten itself yeah it's
its own its own side of the of the the
molecules you just dropped that like it
was a red Skittle and it was like the
most very a lot to unpack in that yeah
yeah I didn't I told you it was more the
answer was deeper than you probably were
bargaining yes wow I really love that
okay so that's what now here's my point
about
um
so in the vegetarian and meat eater
chapter I I just show what it looks like
to a scientist that's all I don't hand
people opinions you have your own
opinion but if you have an opinion How
Deeply have you thought it through
that's right okay so very comedic by the
way oh no yeah oh there you go that's
the con that's the comic principle yeah
so for example uh let's say you're a
vegetarian because you don't don't want
to kill animals yeah right that's a No
One's Gonna like on that okay you
don't want to kill animals you might
even have a Humane mouse trap in your
basement now you have to check on it
every few days because they dry out
quickly once you capture them but if you
find one what do you then do with it you
tell me you release it back into the
wild where it will be murdered where it
will be eaten yeah all right yeah howls
Hawks foxes it it you have doomed it to
a lot yes it is a tasty snack yes for
all manner of Woodland predators and its
life expectancy in the wild is between 9
and 18 months I just released a spider i
j this morning I just released the
spider that's for me that's for me to to
feel better about myself I'm gonna have
to that's what I'm saying so now watch
the best thing you could have done with
the mouse
leave it in your basement in the warmth
and comfort it would live be years a
mouse in captivity can live up to six
years so don't tell me ah you're doing
the mouse a favor
that oh buddy we just had this
conversation don't tell me when you uh
shame an obese person that you care
about their health you would be out
there telling people not to ride
motorcycles not to skydive not to this
is the example of a of a rational lens
brought to people's attitudes and
comments that is exactly what the book
is about that's it it's Cosmic
perspectives on civilization that is
what that is wow yeah well let me keep
my eyes worse please it's worse so
you've saved them saved this mouse you
believe you saved the mouse meanwhile
you are living you don't want to kill
animals but you'll kill plants okay
because you're vegetarian even though
yeah go on okay so now watch but it's
fine you made this distinction so you
live in a home probably made of wood
now you calculate how much wood about
the wood of 50 trees that might have
lived 100 years but you cut them down
early when they're 10 years 20 years 30.
all right so you cut them down early
each tree
each tree was making oxygen enough every
day
that was equal to 15 times the mass of
your chubby little mouse every day
vital oxygen yes for all oxygen
breathing creatures plus the tree serves
as a home for Birds squirrels insects
mushrooms uh all manner of things yes
and it would have lived a hundred years
so I asked you
who does nature care more about
your chubby one ounce Mouse
or the 20 ton tree times 50 that was cut
down to make your home and so my point
here is I want you to be self-aware
of your species bigotry in the Tree of
Life by saying I want to protect animals
but I will eat any plant I choose and
cut down any plant to build my domicile
as if they aren't part of the tapestry
of life I love the Poetry of yourself
the part threads in the tapestry of life
but the entertain interconnectedness
it's operating not only that last point
last Point had it last Point hit it okay
okay
as a vegetarian consider what you're
doing
because I like thinking about aliens
what we look like to aliens so imagine
imagine
plant-based aliens
coming to visit us okay so they just
undergo photosynthesis on their skin so
think about it back in their home planet
there are no kitchens there are no
restaurants there is no food as we know
it
they just lay out under their home star
and get their nourishments and on their
Voyage here they just sit under the
lamps right that's how they are I'm a
little hungry let me get some light
energy okay so they looked in their in
their Taurus catalog that Earth has a
great biodiversity and I want to see
their their light their kind they're
they're kind right they're other plants
so they come to visit Earth and they
confront vegetarians
and they find out that vegetarians not
only eat them but specifically Target
their reproductive organs oh my God nuts
the berries the seeds the the flowers
these you're going after the nuts
they're just trying to make new copies
of themselves and you're going in and
extracting them and eating them not only
that there are there is a there is a
profound infanticide that goes on
because you just go in the produce aisle
of Whole Foods and what do you see
baby carrot baby lettuce baby artichokes
baby baby it's all veal man it's all
veal the veggies are all veal baby
versions yes of the plants so that so
the plant-based aliens
would run home and say this is the
scariest
that is hilarious so this is just a
cosmic perspective yes so do it if you
want but I wanted you to be aware of
what you don't even have a euphemism for
the baby versions of the plants that's
right I love this and I I wonder if this
will blow your mind or at least be
mildly interesting I had a bit Neil I
had a bit and I was like imagine if
aliens land on the planet
and the and the door to the ship opens
and the ramp comes out just like
Spielberg showed us and they're chickens
I mean how quickly people are panicking
to hide the buckets like these are
they're in a superior species when they
find out what we've been doing to their
kind like we're the chicken is
the most slaughtered animal in the world
do you realize Americans
consume
a million chickens per hour
so so it's not just that we eat a
million chickens per hour it's that we
raise feed a farm Harvest bring to
Market a million chickens per hour yeah
that's and I thought you were also going
to bring up uh something A friend
brought up on the podcast which is when
you harvest
um almonds and stuff those machines are
sucking up countless rats Vermin like
there's a lot of death there's a lot of
debt what what I hear you saying correct
me if I'm wrong is there's no real way
out of the we are feasting off of other
life except for milk and honey which is
expressly forbidden by vegans this is
what's amazing to me okay but the two
foods that don't involve killing anybody
any pet no but eat the reproductive
organs of the plants
so what happens is yes but I know the
philosophy of because I know the guy
um um
the philosopher at Princeton who's
largely responsible for the
popularization of vegan um diet Peter
Singer all right so he he means well
he's a good guy and he's smart but my
point back to him was first you have
judged
that if the life form has a brain
it's you would rather preserve it than
life forms that don't have brains so you
have made a a human-centric
observation
protecting species that are closer to
you in the Tree of Life yes but I would
I would say that another way just as an
astrophysicist I would say
it's not that the oak tree doesn't have
a brain
it's that the oak tree doesn't need a
brain oh my God it doesn't need one you
by the way if you cut if you cut down an
oak tree
do the do the leaves not wither like if
not within hours certainly within a half
a day yes that meant there was
circulation there yeah so if you if you
cloak the tree it doesn't matter if you
withdraw its nutrients does it not die
this is like The Merchant of Venice I
hear it does it not bleed it bleeds out
it has a central nervous system and so
don't tell me it's not as good as you
because it doesn't have a brain it's
better than you because it doesn't need
a brain and it will outlive you three
four five times to one the giant
sequoias live a thousand years oh but
I'm gonna protect the mouse because it
has a brain excuse me wow so so the all
this is in the book all of this you're
you're you're watching and think of the
people listening thing there's like a
there's like an earthquake happening in
my brain oh my God
Galileo he coined the term his first
book was Starry Messenger in Latin so it
was siderius nuncius he was looking at
stuff in the universe that told him
different things about what's true then
what he was being told by the holy books
in his day and so this is yeah this was
a great conflict
um because his first book where he
reported on his telescopic observations
Earth was not the center of motion the
moon had blemishes the sun had spots
things were different oh my gosh so I
borrowed his title and gave it a new a
fat subtitle Cosmic perspectives on
civilization I'm looking in the universe
and coming back to Earth and saying this
is what you look like we look like here
on Earth right and so yeah a tree is not
sentient in any way you might care about
but it lives it can live a thousand
years how long can you live right and
what happens between an encounter
between your automobile and a tree on
the side of the road who wins that
encounter yes yes
wow yeah I thought I have another joke
that ends where it's like we're we're
going around eating the other animals
and another if aliens came I'm always
going to the if aliens game if aliens
came the argument I make is if we're all
just staring at our phones and waiting
in line at Spencer's Gift for an apron
that looks like we're naked like they'll
have no problem slaughtering us like
there's like we need to be doing
something better or that the Spencer's
Gift still exist I believe you can find
some like an orange julius it's as rare
as a Julius
but this idea Spencer Gifts they were
like really all the rage in the 80s and
90s I don't know oh for sure yeah no it
was replaced by um what is it uh
Hot Topic Hot Topic is the new Spencer's
Gift all right yeah yeah so we have to
just watch out for ourselves so I throw
in an alien every now and then to
observe what it is who we are and what
we're doing and so did Seinfeld he said
if they so if aliens saw us in fact I
would say the alien perspective is again
just looking for those comments
but it's the comedy perspective and it's
the scientific perspective I think
that's one of the things that we we have
in common Gary Larson had an alien come
down and the alien had this hand-looking
appendage sticking out in front of it
yes and it said uh
unfamiliar with alien Anatomy George
just reaches out and grabs yes the penis
or whatever yeah yeah grabs the extended
appendage yes thinking it was the hand
yes that's the whole thing I've never
considered the the bias we started with
my bias that I won't be getting weaker
and I'll still be able to pick up my
daughter so we had that eager wife yeah
the ego and my wife the ego-based bias
that things that are like me are better
that which which is an insane species
bigotry yes it's species I remember in
um this is like with the dolphins right
yes you know why do you buy line caught
tuna
because Net Car tuna might drag a
dolphin and dolphins are air breathing
and they would be down there and
suffocate right all right so but all
right
what about the tuner you're still
killing me no I know right oh well the
dolphin is a mammal oh so now you they
got the mammal bigotry here so sword or
mammal preference but then don't you
doing this while you're eating a
hamburger aren't you yes yeah that's
right which is a thousand cows by the
way that's one of my you you quoted
something I read in fast food nation
which is a million an hour they also say
there's thousands of cows in every
hamburger which I thought was very
interesting I forget what movie I don't
know what that means there's ground beef
is is the reason we have a hard time
finding mad cow for example the the the
Genesis of that is because there's so
many cows in ground beef like you get it
it's got to be an exaggeration a
thousand I'll give it that it's a number
of more than one but I'm not gonna I
can't believe that it's a thousand
interesting well I it's just something I
read but I really read it doesn't mean
YouTube video I really read it in a
printed book that had another well let
me let me say that differently I'm not
an expert in animal husbandry so I'm not
commenting on expertise I'm just
commenting on slaughterhouses that I've
seen how many cows are in any given spot
that they are slaughtering okay and and
then you know they pull out the stakes
and you pull after this get the rest of
the cow and it gets mixed in with you
know with the ground beef uh I don't
know that that's a thousand cows in any
case there's a lot of cows but I guess
to take it that plant is mixed with
another plant then it all gets to
McDonald's as multiple plants
this is my thesis okay but I don't know
why you would do that right but okay I
don't know either to make it more
difficult to trace mad cows because
they're actually just trying to kill us
I saw something that was making the
argument that there are certain cultures
that will kill one animal that we find
Majestic have you have you thought about
this like they'll kill like a beautiful
whale or something and people like
protest but they're like you're killing
all these it's it's an extension yeah so
that's the so so the point is dolphins
are cuter than tuna yeah that's right
that's right at least at least admit
that to yourself okay you know you want
to feed the squirrel because it has a
bushy tail but you don't want to feed
the rat because it doesn't it's not as
cute right right and they're both
rodents okay so
just get honest where you know it's
interesting environmentally speaking I
don't care what you do just be honest
about it that's all and do and I think
what you want to avoid is people
claiming some sort of moral cachet that
is
that's kind of at the center of a lot of
the the food
bias and the food tribalism that's that
goes on around us yeah that's
interesting what about the so you've
seen you you're you're a mediating
person that had the kind of the stomach
pun there to go to a slaughterhouse and
watch well I've seen I've seen
documentaries oh just documentary
neutral documentaries I was in a film
class in college and there was a
documentary where they take the cow and
cut its throat and the blood spills out
there's another one where they put the
bolt in their head and the drops and the
guy's just smiling and just talking
smoking a cigarette the guy that was
doing it you mean yeah yeah yeah and
it's got the apron but he's just there
and it was it was a European film and it
was just a documentary about a sport it
wasn't even judgy or anything it just
right was and there's exactly but some
people in the class who couldn't watch
it and I said to myself
I eat steak
so I have to force myself to watch this
I don't want to eat steak and not know
that this is going on that would be
dishonest the the marketing of it to
life to and everything so that that
disconnect we we have a cultural
disconnect from our food and our own
deaths there's a lot of marketing going
on yeah there's a lot of you see it at a
wake the way but at the last chapter is
is called life and death yes tell me
tackle the subject of death that we are
so timid around yes here's something
interesting uh
uh just to show you how deeply religious
we are even when we're not okay
so
you go into a funeral home
and usually there's more than one you
know room there's only one gathering in
any given evening but
it's not the only body around so
you don't walk into the funeral director
and say
where's Freddy
you say where is the body where's the
bread yeah where's the body
so you are implicitly agreeing that
there is some soul substance yes that
left his body
it is now somewhere else that which was
Fred is something else now and the body
is there she said where is the body of
Fred not where is Fred right I'm
fascinated by that that's also comedy
that's a comedy perspective you would
never say I'm gonna go say hi to Fred
you'd say I'm gonna pay my respects
you're gonna say like I gotta see the
body right the body the body yeah yeah
yeah yeah wow those same molecules
there's nothing missing it's all there
but a formaldehyde mixed in or whatever
they mix the butt the you could say your
refrigerator is still your refrigerator
when you unplug it but you know it's not
keeping your food cold though it's it's
not doing the thing that made it a
refrigerator like when I'm dead I won't
be doing the thing that mostly people
came to me for
correct however so
so you are you are admitting that's the
wrong word you were declaring yeah
there's a spirit essence of your friend
that is no longer there and so you must
only then reference its body right now
and if that's the case yeah this is not
in the book but I'm thinking of it in
this moment if you recognize that then
what do you care what happens to the
body
what do you care why should there be a
monument over the body in the ground if
the secret Essence is somewhere else
that's one of my favorite Simpsons jokes
where mod and Ned Flanders are almost
taken away by a tornado and my Flanders
is that the religion and she goes oh
Nettie I was almost taken off to Eternal
Paradise With God it was terrible
it was just like
that is one of those things that we're
afraid we don't really believe so it's a
little bit like whistling in the dark
where I I mean you're talking to
somebody who is deeply spiritual and I I
don't we will get into that but even I
I'll catch myself liking those language
choices because you're like there's
always going to be a part of you that's
like maybe I'm wrong so you like it you
want to keep it going
not for you not for you no I'm still
looking at evidence for things I'm very
evidence driven yeah right well you know
what's interesting that's one of my big
questions for you is you're looking for
evidence with the thing we're looking
for right I mean this this is but
consider consider someone who Strokes
out
okay yes
um they're not there anymore even though
they're Fully Alive sitting in a
wheelchair right but you're not going to
say where is the body of
dad you're gonna say where's Nana yeah
yeah or Nana yeah you're gonna say
where's Nana because they're breathing
and their heart is beating
because their Spirit energy is no longer
there because we know and everything
that is you is in your brain and the
neurosynaptic
biochemistry going on in your brain and
so your brain shuts down as The Strokes
take out sectors of your brain now
you're basically a vegetable
um no one refers to it as the body of
who was once there but so so we have
these I'm not complaining that we're
inconsistent we're just observing they
were inconsistent and that intrigues me
as an observer of culture couldn't be
more intrigued I do think it's
interesting it's like where do you
define so Nana who's stroked out and is
in a wheelchair there's still a
operating there's still the the blank
there's a blank piece of paper happening
meaning there's still awareness inside
of her we can't know but there's
something going on that there's activity
like she's she's there no her basal body
functions continue because the brain
protects those as the last thing to go
but she's not having any thoughts
there's no it's not like in a coma where
the brain is still active and activated
there's just a disconnect between what's
going on outside your sensory system and
what's going on inside so it's not like
a coma when you're brain dead there's
nothing happening processing of
information right it's more just dead
well except your heart is beating so
you're not going to say the body is
that's all right no that's interesting
yeah that's that's that's that's
something I'm gonna have to keep
thinking about okay that's a good
virtual man okay not right now not right
now
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at lmnt element healthy
hydration isn't just about drinking
water it's about drinking water plus
electrolytes it makes sense you lose
both water and sodium When you sweat and
both need to be replaced to prevent
muscle cramps headaches and energy dips
but most people only replace the water
why because since the 1940s people have
been telling us to drink eight glasses
of water a day whether you're thirsty or
not but that's actually a terrible idea
drinking Beyond thirst is a bad idea it
dilutes blood electrolyte levels
especially sodium which can lead to
headache low energy cramps confusion or
worse and the solution to getting
through your workout or just getting
through your day with proper hydration
to optimize your body and your mind
isn't just to drink water it's to drink
water plus electrolytes so enter drink
lmnt element has become a huge part of
my personal wellness program and a part
of my morning routine that I really look
forward to I always start every day with
a huge glass of water and a packet of
lmnt I like their watermelon salt flavor
you just mix it up super easy tastes
great and you're good to go no sugar or
artificial junk just electrolytes and
great taste that that provides the
ultimate ratio of sodium potassium and
magnesium that help with your health
performance and your energy it also
tastes amazing and when I'm fasting
which I do intermittent fasting but I
still want to sip something flavorful
like not break my fast it is a wonderful
thing it's a wonderful asset keeps my
fast on track and makes fasting easier
element has come up with a fantastic
offer for weirdos just go to
drinklmnt.com weird use promo code weird
to get a free element sample pack with
any order when you order if element
doesn't exceed your expectations they
have a no question to ask refund policy
you don't even have to send it back so
support your body support the show go to
drink
lmnt.com weird and get your free sample
pack with any purchase that's drink
lmnt.com
weird this episode is also brought To Us
by our friends at betterhelp Getting to
Know Yourself can be a lifelong process
especially because we're always growing
and changing like before I went to
therapy I personally had no idea what
codependency was or how to end a
relationship in a healthy way or set up
boundaries with family and people I work
with but that's what therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
your understanding because sometimes we
don't know what we want we don't know
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things with a professional
better help connects you with just that
professional they connect you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are because the more you
know about yourself the more easily you
can maneuver through life with less
suffering and more clarity relationships
grief loss anxiety you named it talk
therapy has changed my life talking with
a professional helps so if you're
interested in starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com weirdo
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better health
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo and speaking of
Health wellness and rituals ritual is a
huge part of my morning ritual time out
it's supporting foundational Health was
a sport who would you want on your team
would choose ritual they made a
multivitamin for men that's based solely
on science and designed to help fill
common nutrient gaps in the diet with 10
key nutrients I used to for real go to
the doctor and they would tell me which
vitamins I was deficient in it's just a
normal occurrence I started taking a
ritual completely turned that around
it's minty it's got everything that I'm
missing I don't eat a lot of meat I
don't need a lot of dairy it's got that
B12 it's got that D it's got all the
things that I need to fill in the gaps
scientifically develop multivitamin with
high quality key nutrients in clean
bioavailable forms ritual is a new type
of two a day for helping support heart
health with omega-3 DHA to normal muscle
function to normal immune function with
vitamin D3 this small step can have a
major impact and all the nutrition in it
is completely traceable because where
your nutrients come from is just as
important as where they're for and also
it's not the biggest criticism I hear
for vitamins is that you just pee it out
this is a delayed release capsule it
weights it until it's in your lower and
testing a breakdown which means you're
actually going to absorb it which it
means it's going to actually make a huge
difference in your body and for me make
you feel ready to start your day it's
vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free and major allergen free
essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust and get this ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months so support your
body support your show visit ritual.com
weird to start ritual or add essential
for men to your subscription today
that's ritual.com weird alright
everybody back to Neil deGrasse Tyson
not right now not right now you know
let's play my bit I I I I I spoke to
your someone that's working with you
they maybe said that you've seen this
bit and I want if you would honor me I'm
gonna I I caught bits I know others
oddly I know many of your other work but
not that one bit oh okay this is your
space uh this is my space bed I this is
weird to say I hope you like it that's
my hope it doesn't really no I'm not
don't worry about me I'm not no no I
will I will like as a minimum I will
like your effort there it is that's all
I ask but I'm a third grade teacher
gives you this the star for effort yeah
and you'll put my my hand paste drawing
on the fridge like a loving parent even
if it's completely off but here's what I
want because I've heard this joke before
I'd like you to call out pause anytime
you have a thought
is that good
I thought about what about what I'm
saying like I'm gonna say some stuff uh
some scientists
you say Katie is going to play First you
say pause and I'd love to hear your
thoughts because this is my most famous
uh bit and I'd love to put it and I'll
tell you up top a lot of it is based on
something Bill Nye told me so I took
something he taught me and ran with it
so uh one of your contemporaries I
suppose we could say but I'd love to
hear the Neil deGrasse and Bill Nye uh
uh after his engineering degree began as
a comedian is that right yes I'm sure we
covered that so he has timing he has
certain timings that come from I love it
I love it but but I I
I wanna hear the whole thing okay
I'll interrupt you then let's do this
our art I'll pause it I'll pause it when
I know we're about to shift topics okay
that way you won't feel rude chapter yes
okay that's right yeah the little little
uh footnote okay so um Katie uh let's
play it and oh you can't recreate it
here I got the lot the living man
himself no but no I gotta hear a
recording of you okay honestly Neil I
couldn't remember the words if you gave
me a hundred thousand dollars it's an
old joke so here we're gonna listen to
it together Katie go ahead
what I'm saying is enjoy everything this
is all we have or maybe it's not I don't
know
I won't make fun of your answers does
anybody hear a clap if you believe in an
afterlife
clap if you don't believe in it but
you're open to it you don't think
there's evidence but you're open to it
anybody reincarnation reincarnation
and who thinks it's just dead over you
just unplug the TV
I think you're all right
those are all correct answers what I
think is funny about it though is all my
friends think it's dead over they just
think you unplug the TV and it lights
out they all say the same thing to me
they're just like Pete think about it
afterlife
makes no sense
makes no sense and afterlife
you think an afterlife makes sense you
got to think about that again because in
afterlife
afterlife makes no sense
I was like yeah I agree with you
you know what else makes no sense
this
life makes no sense so I would
argue that life sets a precedent for
potentially more that makes no
sense does that make sense
[Applause]
I see a lot Brewing Katie we've got a
pause a quick just so the opening quote
of my best-selling book it is
the universe is under no obligation to
make sense to you love that that's from
2017 uh that was the national physicist
no it's that one uh what was the title
of that book give me a second
astrophysics for people in a hurry okay
love that I need a little book great
that was my opening quote just so that
when I told you that the Universe began
in the size smaller than the size of an
atom and grew to be as big as it is
don't come back to me say that makes no
sense right I'm saying
the universe doesn't care that you think
it makes sense what do you make of the
hypothesis I love the accent of your of
your friend
you're really picking up on those little
tricks that's the trick I love your
friends your friends it's like the dude
on the street corner right that's not
that's not the person getting straight
A's in your class that's just some Joe
on the street corner that's right every
comedian needs a good dumb guy voice and
that you just heard mine what do you
make of the of the idea that if things
don't make sense it kind of stands to
reason that there might be more things
that don't make sense completely
yes no argument here love it should we
keep listening let's go all right Katie
go ahead
but my friends are all like nah man
there's this that we all
almost asked for
and then no more
it's a one-time deal
what nothing makes sense life
makes no sense you're on a planet right
now
you think you're in America zoom out
you're on a space rock floating in
nothingness infinite nothingness and the
infinite nothingness is expanding that
means endlessness is getting bigger that
makes no sense okay pause there
Katie okay okay so
um I didn't see this on YouTube but I
heard it on a comedy channel oh so yes
I'm reconfirmed okay good
what I like about it is
no one
can argue with you
you're being bluntly
honest and accurate
when it makes no
we're on a planet in the middle of
nothing and we're getting more
nothingness
right keep going
I got no rebuttal because yes let me not
stop you keep going on that yes yes
should we keep going yeah no so I'm just
saying oh no way so typically if a
comedian is mid routine you're you're
thinking
could they've done something differently
or better or funny or whatever and you
just have everyone in the palm of your
hands right now because we're thinking
about it and say damn he's right oh
he's why is he right I don't want him
he's right
damn okay that's where that that's where
that's Landing okay okay feeling
irritate go ahead Katie
we all just act like it's normal like oh
where everything's made of molecules
okay
got it I'll never think about that again
I made it but okay I got one for you
ready hit it please okay
most people don't know how small
molecules are they have no idea yeah no
idea so I'm going to tell you tell me
there are more molecules of water
in a glass of water
then there are glasses of water in all
the world's oceans
wow which means
that after you drink that water
and it comes back out of you any number
of a half a dozen ways
there's enough molecules that pass
through your kidney
to populate every single other possible
glass of water drawn from the world
water supply wow which means the glass
of water you did draw
from your faucet contains molecules that
definitely pass through the kidneys of
Abraham Lincoln of Jesus yes Miss Khan
oh pick any historical figure
wow
there are enough molecules to do that
that's how little they are and the same
works for air
there are more molecules of air in a
breath of air
then there are breaths of air in the
entire atmosphere of the earth stop it
so that when you breathe in and exhale
they're molecules that you inhaled that
went through the lungs of Adolf Hitler
of Mother Teresa of and so so think
about it
what that means for our connectivity yes
we are a shared organism in a way yes
with the water and the air we are
participants in the consumption of this
life-sustaining
blood of the planet called Water and Air
so that's the back story to your
molecules I love that it's like the the
parable of what the hell is water the
two fish going what the hell is water we
act like it's normal but sometimes I
like to think of the of air being
gelatinous just to help me Envision to
visualize just how connected it all is I
think I'm over here you're over there
but we're connected by the the the the
air resting on our skin and and when you
talk about the even smaller particles
and then air moves wind currents take it
it scatters into the entire atmosphere
yes yes yeah the bit continues with more
stuff I want to hear
I'm made of molecules you're made of
molecules the air between us it's all
made of molecules that makes no
sense these molecules know their
molecules
these molecules are like I'm Pete that
doesn't make any sense
this stool is made of molecules the same
molecules in my hand in fact some of the
molecules in the stool went into me
while I've been talking and some that
were me have gone into this stool and
you know when I knock these molecules
into these molecules when we ask science
why don't they go through each other you
know what the answer is
we don't know
you gotta pause there no we do know but
we'll give you that tell me because that
was the side so first let me start by
saying I'm a big fan of Mark Twain's
edict
first get your facts straight then
distort them at your leisure
yeah it's love so you were you were
Waist Deep
and authentically fund science here and
I'm going to give you one where you say
they don't know I'll give you a hall
pass on that one I got it I got it from
Bill I swear he said yeah no no sir why
do these repel why do these molecules
repel these molecules so so the problem
is more philosophical than that because
we know why they repel because there's a
force field called electromagnetic
fields and molecules do not pass through
one another because electromagnetic
forces prevent it it's an actual Force
that's empowered by the fact that these
particles have charge plus and minus
charge and so so that's the answer but
if you want a deeper answer
why does the field exist as caused by
the truck you can take y all the way
down and there'll be some point say I'll
just say shut up it just works that way
yeah yeah yeah but what about the ones
that are leaking out I saw you nodding
the molecules in my microphone and me
Little League no it's just in contact
anytime two things contact they're
molecules that exchange is that what it
is I thought it was I pictured it as
like naps like flying out some might
evaporate off like the surface of a
liquid or something yeah but very solid
objects if you come in contact okay so
if you take your hand and just rub it
across a surface we just keep doing it
there's friction and your hand warms up
yeah those are molecules trading back
and forth you have skin molecules on the
table and the table left wood molecules
in your hand yes wow you kept at it
you'll rub away the Finish you'll rub
away the outer surface of your skin
there's stuff going on there wow one
swipe you don't notice it or think about
it but if you kept that up you'll see
that the net effect of what you're doing
over time
it's it's kind of a chicken egg thing
but it's like we love touch we love it
stop go ahead we got the chicken egg
solved
hey it was the egg yeah the egg came
first
you know what I meant though
well no I'm just saying yeah find
another one yes I understand I got the
chicken you know why it was the egg tell
me the egg was laid by a bird that was
not a chicken
and then it evolved right it's always
part of the application between the bird
that was not a Chicken and the Egg that
it laid and then they open the egg and
that's a chicken and its parent is not a
chicken does the question go back to
that bird then like so we compress yeah
the whole evolutionary thing into this
simple exercise of the egg
came first because it was laid by a bird
that was not a chicken okay so now
what's your question oh no I I think I
know your answer I think everybody might
have a guess the bird that laid it that
was a nag and it goes all the way back
to like single cell organisms basically
no we were just talking about chickens
we want to know about birds
okay what is the bird you know what came
first the bird or the Egg that's a
different question yeah yeah yeah but
chicken or chicken in the egg that one's
retired but chicken is yeah but we
retired the Chicken and the Egg so help
me the question I do have for you an
electromagnetic field is like the
outline if I'm a cartoon that's like the
outline around me the black line
it is the volume over which a force will
be enacted with the right kind of
particle for it to act on
so Gravity the field is everywhere I let
go of something it drops yes a gravity
field
and mass in a gravity field responds to
the force of gravity by Falling Towards
the center of the object if I had an
electric field and I had a neutral
object it is not responsive to the
electromagnetic field we'll just stay
there if I give it a charge it'll start
moving wow in response to the field yeah
fascinating this is a real honor I'm I'm
really enjoying this keep keep going
Katie there's only a little more
thing if I die listen to me if I died
and it was just kitty cat Thanksgiving
I'd be like yeah okay
makes about as much sense as the
conundrum I was just stuck in
it's the gravy okay we can stop there
that's basically the end yeah so I I've
actually heard that routine many times
but not not on video so so I didn't
necessarily connect it to you yeah just
hearing it um say listen to comedy radio
often I love that I love to think of you
doing that is is it I'm I'm now I'm
trying to like poke holes in myself by
the way you know a little hat tip to Sam
Kinison there oh yeah yeah oh yeah I'm
definitely the the funny anger doesn't
make sense yeah yeah you lose your
control right and you can't you have to
emote the next sentence rather than
deliver it it's huge that joke on paper
isn't really a joke it's all attitude
it's all it's it's demonstrating my
frustration absolutely for sure so I
wonder this is my own attempt at poking
a hole in myself is it dangerous to
say because this doesn't make sense is
it like circular logic or something I'm
saying this doesn't make sense so
therefore Anything Could Happen is that
dangerous yeah no just because you don't
understand what's happening doesn't mean
what's happening isn't completely
following rules that we've established
for it right
so go on so so
um I mean there's plenty of stuff that's
just kind of yeah why is that happening
but it's going to happen exactly the way
we described and quantum physics is a
lot of that uh you've heard of bits on a
computer uh bit is either zero or a one
it's literally binary all right but a
quantum computer doesn't use bits it
uses qubits
a q letter Q bit Sometimes some people
say quit but I'd like just the q q a bit
all right and what is a qubit it can be
a zero or a one or any
combination of the two at any given time
ninety percent one ten percent zero
ninety percent zero tap 50 50. the qubit
is a statistical combination of the two
because that doesn't make any sense it
does to quantum physics predict it we
know exactly what's going to do and when
it's gonna happen and we can exploit
that with computer circuitry right but
why does it have I have no idea but it
is right I guess what I'm saying is I'm
tying this things don't make sense to
the afterlife meaning you Neil deGrasse
Tyson die and it's like the old Steve
Martin joke you see the Pearly Gates his
bit was like he'd be like oh no how like
like all that they told us all this was
in college I'm just saying what
I'm trying I guess because you know what
wait you know you know um
uh
Richard Dawkins reply to that did that
Steve Martin joke no no well to in that
same scenario oh okay because they ask
you he's a you know Arjun atheist they
ask you yes what happens when you die
and you and you at the Pearly Gates and
God and you meet God what are you going
to say to God yes and he'll say
why
did you
work so hard
to not be detectable by any means than
anybody
what what
diabolical you know like why the cat and
mouse why the hide and seek
yeah yeah no I completely I used to
think that all the time when I was a
much more straight laced theist I was
like why doesn't God just one time open
up the clouds and go hello I'm here now
shut the up and get back to work
and knowing that I'm looking at you
right that'd be really easy to that I
would say I feel like you and I are both
branches off a tree trunk called
awareness right I I don't mean to get
too new AG but like there's a phenomenon
of Consciousness that's a good new age
there that is like the most new agey
thing scary new agey right there okay
but you and I are aware right
they help me out I feel like the
difference between you you like any good
comedian notices stuff being aware you
if you don't that's I see them as the
same thing if you don't notice stuff
you've got nothing to joke about I
completely agree but the number one
thing that most people don't stop and
notice is that there is something that
is a I'm not saying it's God I'm saying
there is a uh awareness there is
something that is aware of your
experience whether you're dreaming
whether whether you're drinking
because how do I know because I you are
in my awareness I I there's something is
here I'm aware of you yeah yeah but if
you're out in the wilderness what do you
mean well I'm aware of the Wilderness
but is the Wilderness aware of you
uh that that's an interesting question
voting in space I thought you were
saying that people don't notice that
you are noticed by some entity
I'm saying when you sing Happy Birthday
in your head right now
what is hearing that when when you hear
a voice in your head okay you just okay
so you're being you're being Descartes
on us and you're saying I think
therefore I am
I am because I think I would reverse it
okay sure sure yeah
what do you that that's I think that's
the most overlooked thing the most
overlooked phenomenon is what I would
use the new age word of awareness your
internal evidence of your own existence
right exactly and people so that's when
Richard Dawkins is like God why didn't
you make yourself more perceivable or
more findable I feel like the answer is
I was looking out your eyes the whole
time I was awareness like the like the
Old Testament God said to Moses I am
that I am I am emness so the amnest that
looks out your eyes and the amnest that
looks at my eyes is kind of the what we
use the metaphor for of God to describe
that does that make sense
uh okay so therefore when you you can
come and go but that entity you're
describing would then manifest in other
people who are not dead that's right
does that make sense
uh okay we're glasses of water and
there's an ocean of awareness and you
and I are momentary refractions of that
infinite awareness
okay so that's uh it Harkens back to
Carl Sagan's one of his famous quotes
um we are a way for the universe to know
itself yes exactly so we had interview
I'm not saying God he's just saying he
says the Universe I like there's a
determine a book I was reading about
Madonna they were like God just means
origin it's been so misused the the
first
vedanta uh non-dualism it's just a fancy
word for non-dualism non-dualism yeah
see I I'm I'm not into isms
you're out on isms and I just every time
I hear about an ism it involves we have
to we believe this in this Doctrine in
this book and that is our ISM and I just
I don't want to be in ISM I want to not
I want to be ISM free in my life it's
interesting we were kind of flirting
with non-dualism when we were talking
earlier about the interconnectivity of
the the trees breathe off this and we
breathe in this so we there you get that
sense of a of a Harmony that feels like
a maybe I would say that the universe is
fundamentally non-dual but that doesn't
mean I should have a word for it all
right so so
why should there be a word for something
that it isn't if that's the normal if
that's the the native state of things I
think there's uh this is out of my pay
grade when it comes to non-uh
non-dualism there's a reason why they
don't call it singularism because
they're just saying what it's not
they're saying it's not to and there's
some caveat there's a reason why they do
that and I don't know it well
okay I can tell you this that uh I get
to this in the two chapters of the book
um color and race yeah I went there and
gender and identity where we are lazy in
our heads we take something that would
exist on a Continuum on a spectrum and
we will compartmentalize it just so that
it's easier for us to think about it
right so for example you say are you a
boy or are you a girl well I'm feeling a
little both today no no you gotta be a
boy or your girl well you want me to fit
into your categories so that you'll be
happy really is that really what's
happening here today I feel 90 feminine
and 10 masculine and and although how
about your chromosomes your X all right
remember okay you can speak
chromosomally are you male or female
holding aside the the the the rare
genetic variations on that chromosome
you can be male or female
fine
in life
is are we looking at your chromosomes
really really let's think about this
okay and I did this experiment in the
subway and I repeated it elsewhere but
the subway everyone is seated all right
the good thing about being seated in
this experiment is most of the
difference in people's height is in
their legs
men on average are taller than women but
seated everybody levels out okay and you
know this because
shares the seat and cars
moves much more forward and backwards
than it does up and down that's true as
a six foot six man yeah that's very true
yes it's to accommodate your legs but
but your height a six foot six man might
be six inches taller than a five foot
six woman
when he's actually a foot tall but about
six inches taller seated yes if that the
seats are around a board table in a
board room they can adjust up and down
but rarely is someone really doing that
yeah yeah someone sits down with their
nose at the table I gotta be crank
myself up again right that's very
interesting that's not what you'd get
with height point is
um
my point is everyone's about the same
height and I said can I identify who's
male and who's female and I went down
the list
a hundred percent accurate okay
well all right well who's female
well these are the people who have on
average longer hair their jewelry is
more visible there is eyeliner more
likely there is tweezed between the
eyebrows more likely there is
um and you just go down the list yes and
then you realize that almost everything
I was queuing on is a secondary or
tertiary add-on
to whatever your chromosomes were that
morning
I'm not looking at your chromosomes I'm
observing the beauty industrial complex
at work on your face
yes okay and what happens if your your
breasts are not big enough you bake them
bigger okay Americans have 300
000 breast enlargement surgeries every
year
oh because you because you're apparently
your chromosomes weren't visible enough
so let's boost that part of it let's put
on the makeup let's put on the the blush
or the Rouge whatever it's called you
put on the foundation you put on so
that's a girl clothing and the nails are
done that's a girl who's the boy well
like the boy might have been a little
skinny so they go to the gym and they
get bigger muscles so they know how to
dress because the fashion industry tells
you how to dress if you want to be a boy
they tell you what clothes to wear no
you're not going to wear a dress the
girl is going to wear a dress why
because society says so the chromosomes
don't give a rat's ass whether air blows
up between your legs or not
so like color skirt what it is it's just
your access to leg air yeah okay leg
hair so my point is it was completely
clear
who was a boy and who was a girl by
secondary and tertiary indicators so
what I'm saying is if I'm chromosomally
a boy and I feel like being a girl today
I have all manner of tactics that have
nothing to present as a girl yes that
have nothing to do Ambiguously as a girl
and isn't that in fact I discussed this
in the in the gender and identity
chapter the point is
you need me to be a boy or girl because
you have a binary brain but I'm saying
no I am fluid here deal with it by the
way I read somewhere did I read
somewhere that that
the pursuit of happiness was a goal of
the these new United States
of happiness and I want to be half boy
half girl today or neither right or
neither all right now you won't know
this is Pat all over again from SNL now
you don't know right right right now you
have anxiety about this but I don't I'm
comfortable in my own self that's what I
was going to say isn't it fear driven
there's like a there are these agreed it
goes back to the trees don't matter as
much as the amount it's this I see what
you're doing and it's fascinating I I
have to get this book I can't wait to
read that I hope you read the audiobook
because the the way you did I did read
the audiobook thank you thank you this
is just what a gift you don't have to
say that right
yes I did read the audiobook yeah quiet
page turn
I get your ASMR going here yeah
absolutely uh okay love love love let me
ask you one thing because we're we're
coming to close here I'm so touched that
you took this time
I need to tell you what Lee is so the
the smear of Cosmos behind you sort of
looks like a room I was just listening
I'm in front of the Karina nebula of
vicarina the James Webb Space Telescope
which is a site of intense
it's a stellar Nursery where stars are
being born at a very high rate deep
within the gas cloud stars are made of
gas you would expect to find them born
in gas clouds and indeed they are well
well you went full Neil degrass
Cosmos
are you kidding me gives people the
chills you're you're reintroducing
mystery and Majesty what a gift you are
Lee is the study of that looks like a
river like the back of a turtle looks
like certain types of rock patterns that
you sometimes see when you're flying
over the the Earth Europa looks like uh
the Deep art it's the it's the just the
appreciation of how a bolt of lightning
looks like a branch of a tree that sort
of thing okay so it's making
connectivity it's just that yeah so I I
think that could be taken to limits that
are unjustified so for example people
will look at the web of galaxies in the
universe because they don't they don't
only just cluster they form filaments
and just like if you cut a sponge and
you looked at the where the sponge
material is it wraps around holes so
when we look for galaxies in the
universe what we had historically been
calling clusters are just where these
filaments intersect as they continue as
filaments Beyond where they are anyhow
the the
all right so people will look at that
and then they'll look at the neuro
imagery of the brain and they'll say
this is the same thing maybe yes the
universe is a brain right and they it so
completely different thing that happens
to look similar right somebody mentioned
that to me like the movements of an atom
electrons in an atom does not mirror the
movements of Planets For example one or
two and that's why it has the same word
you know people looked in the atom and
say wow there's a nucleus and stuff that
orbits it it's just like the universe
maybe it's that all the way down and all
the way up yeah right so it goes all the
way down like the like the Galaxy on the
belt of Orion uh the cat in in Men In
Black oh yeah that's right okay that's
about how it ends as as the camera zooms
out so so don't make me out pop culture
you here
I think he just did and I'm just
struggling along trying to keep up with
you you're doing fantastic culture
observers so
I'm so what point was I making we were
talking about Lee being taken too far
sometimes
and so when we did discover the atom and
so maybe the electrons are like the
planets and they have orbits and they're
not orbits it turns out but we still
retain the root of the word and so
planets surround the nucleus in orbitals
um see so it got a little kiss from the
solar system see what I'm you're just
like a a defender of reality there's
such a satisfaction to coming to New
conclusions and always growing and
expanding on those things here's the
question I have to ask you I'd kick
myself does nothing exist the I have a
new joke that I've been doing talking
about how some people think uh An Origin
of force like a an unborn infinite thing
that we can call God erupted into the
big bang I know I'm oversimplifying here
and some people think that was spurned
by nothing right and in the joke I said
kind of say like it's funny people say
God doesn't exist but nothing definitely
doesn't exist the the fundamental
characteristic of nothing is that it
doesn't exist so I'm trying to make the
argument that we're all kind of
doing our best like we're using words to
explain something that's very hard to
explain does nothing exist
so it turns out there are levels of
nothing
okay
hear me are you ready to tell me
everything
okay I don't you know I don't want to
delay your Slumber this evening because
you're staring hopelessly at the ceiling
yes longing for a cookie and a cup of
warm milk uh so
think about
before we fully understood air if you're
sending it across from me I would say
there's nothing between us because I can
see you if there's something here I
wouldn't be able to see you oh well what
are you breathing well there's air or
what is air I don't know so you can find
molecules and we understood molecules
now we know there's stuff between us all
right what happens if you get rid of the
molecules
okay
then you have a vacuum well how well can
you do that well there's
interplanetary space
which is as good a vacuum as existed
ever anywhere on Earth
but there's still a few months there's
like a molecule every cubic foot
okay
that's still not nothing
we'll do nothing between the molecules
well let's keep going look Intergalactic
space that's one molecule per
you know 100 cubic meters that's really
empty okay but that molecule is still
there they're still doing its thing all
right okay
um
remove all molecules
that now what's there well
if you put an object there and let go it
would fall towards a source of gravity
the gravitational field was there hmm
not nothing not nothing nothing is not
just whether there's a particle there is
there a field there okay if there's a
field there what's the field made of
and our best explanation of fields is is
what's called virtual particles
okay that pop in and out of existence
and you they don't live long enough to
detect them but to create this sort of
energy of the vacuum
okay hmm and so that's there
and you turns out you can't get rid of
that because quantum physics
demands that there is no place where
there is no energy okay all right but
let's pretend you could get rid of it
um
are there still laws of physics that
apply there
maybe a true nothing is not only where
there's no matter and no virtual
particles and no shape of the fabric of
space-time which is what gravity does to
space maybe it's a place where they're
not even laws of physics themselves
Ben how do you even interact with it all
interactions engage some law of physics
to enable the interaction in the first
place
if you have a place where there is
nothing not even the laws of physics to
me that's as good and nothing as you'll
ever find
and look I'm not going to burden you
with answering a very the oldest
question we have but if we have that
place no virtual particles no waves no
physics no gravity
is it can we agree that that's a like a
it's a strange guess for the why why not
universes popping out of other universes
you know what I'm saying like we have
that
well yeah no I know but we have that
this is this is the Multiverse so by the
way between there's a version of the
Multiverse there's several concepts of
the Multiverse in one of them the laws
of physics are slightly different from
one to the other but you can ask what's
between those universes because they're
embedded in a higher dimension so would
a totally nothing spot also have no
dimensionality
if it has Dimensions is that a thing
right right that's right how would you
talk about something that has no objects
no Fields no shape no laws of physics
and not even Dimensions I would call it
God that's that's kind of what I'm
saying is okay so what you got to watch
out you gotta watch out
you better watch out you gotta watch it
because
I'm just alerting you you don't want
your God
to exist and thrive
in all places where science has yet to
tread
right because science continues to
progress and if that's your definition
of God
where science has yet to tread then God
is an Everest thank God to you is it
ever ever receding proceeding of
scientific ignorance right well one day
disappear into it you see I I'm actually
not trying to catch science and go like
aha so now you haven't shined the light
over there I'm going to call that God
I'm just saying like if I did I I
explained to nothing that we don't even
know how to talk about the nothing he
said there's God
I've had people say what was around
before the Big Bang I said I don't know
we got to talk to people working top
people we're gonna must have been God I
have people that say uh tell me about
dark energy this mysterious pressure
that permeates all of space and forces
us to expand you it was in your joke
okay
um if not so explicitly it was there and
so
so listen what is dark energizing I
don't know we've got top people working
on it that must be God they're people
who are reaching groping for God to be
every place that science is not
there was a day when we looked up at the
night sky saw planets going back and
forth and we invented words for it like
retrograde because we thought planets
actually went backwards if you're in the
center of the universe that's the only
accounting for them right so we did all
this and then that was did anybody
understand it no but there was not a
problem because it was the sky that's
God God lives there you were just mortal
brains there's no way you could
understand that so give it to God and
shut up about it Isaac Newton we first
get the sun back in the middle of the
known universe then Isaac Newton
describes all the planets with his
universal law of gravitation do you know
people came up to him and said
Isaac
[Laughter]
you've left nothing for God to do
damn near accused him of heresy for that
right again religious guy by the way I I
I did do what you said that I did I
guess the spirit in which I was doing is
trying to say the the same sidedness
meaning both the spiritual and the
scientific are trying to understand
something that keeps bringing us to
places that you can't see touch taste
photograph you know what I'm saying like
there's accept no except that no okay
epilepsy was devil inhabiting the body
very clear clear sign of the devil in
your body you're writhing on the ground
and back then all right when it's the
devil in the body you lived in a town
how far away was the church like three
blocks you know in town just enough time
to go to the church get the priest and
put on the robe get the holy water walk
to the walk to your home bless the thing
exercise
the devil and then the symptoms fade
away
just as epilepsy symptoms do even if the
priest didn't show up okay
no
I'm telling you yes that was a fully
understood phenomenon to the Catholic
priests
hmm
we have answered that phenomena we know
what causes it we can't fully control it
but we know what's going on inside your
head and we can address it we can Tamp
it down so we're still working on it but
we know it's not the devil right okay so
don't say that religious people and
scientists are those neck and neck look
finding things that are mysterious and
then wondering about them we are finding
things that are mysterious and solving
them and then moving on okay
let me finish the Newton story you
realize Newton invented calculus right
this is a smart dude he invented
calculus and he he calculates the moon's
orbit around the Earth got that
Earth's orbit around the sun got that
Jupiter's moons orbiting around Jupiter
got that his universal law of
gravitation applied here there
everywhere okay
but
he could not solve the full solar system
story
because watch every time we come around
the back stretch and Jupiter is out
there we move faster than Jupiter in
orbit so we passed Jupiter
um you know every year and a month or so
every year in a couple of months so
Jupiter's out and it has gravity every
time we come around Jupiter is going to
tug on us a little bit
when we're closest to you but it's going
to tug
and Newton knew this
and he said all the planet it's not just
the sun and the planet in orbit all the
planets are tugging on each other holy
after enough time the whole solar system
is going to fly apart but he knew his
equations worked for pairs of objects
but he's he but he saw that the
long-term fate of the solar system was
unstable and you know what he said
he said well I know my equations work
and I know the Solar System's still here
so
he actually says this in his famous book
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy it says lone mentioned second
one of two mentions of God he says
all right how we why doesn't the solar
system fly apart God must step in every
now and then to rectify things hmm
he's done doesn't have to explain it any
further
a hundred years later
six times seven a hundred years later
someone Pierre de la place of French
obviously French mathematician
develops a branch of calculus
called perturbation Theory
Newton could have done that
between breakfast and lunch because he
invented calculus to begin with this is
just a branch of calculus that didn't
occur to Newton to invent okay
what is perturbation Theory it
calculates what happens when you have
many little tugs when there's one major
tug and you can mathematically solve the
problem and show that the solar system
is stable
because all the little tugs cancel out
Because by the time the Earth comes
around the other side everything but
he's pulling them back that way and back
there but you can mathematically
demonstrate they cancel Newton couldn't
do that all right so he writes this in a
book called Celestial mechanics a huge
five volume thing this is the French guy
the French guy Napoleon orders Up the
Volume Napoleon was very deeply red in
physics and Mathematics so he knew not
only how to at engineering no no knew
not only how to make cannonballs but
where they were going to fall and what
they would hit and what damage they
would do this is Napoleon not just not
only just a little Tyrant the boy knew
some engineering and physics ordered up
this book read it cover to cover
summoned them to this office and said
LaPlace
uh this is a brilliant piece of work
but you make no mention
of the architect
of the system
that's his comment about God and that's
the god reference that Newton was making
but you may and you know what LaPlace
replied
sir I had no need for that hypothesis
mic drop in whatever they would have
dropped okay maybe a croissant or
something
drop
I mean that is a badass story yeah so
what I'm saying is
even Newton fell victim to a god of the
gaps
he has this book that's just nothing but
math and physics in it then he gets to
something he can't explain so God fixes
it right
what about the idea that that the fact
that math works in the order and all
that does that lend itself to a language
of of not order not human bias wish
fulfilling order but isn't it what do
you make of like the language of math
applying so beautifully and perfectly
and so far out
does that ever give you that the
spiritual thread going here that
Spinoza's God okay so Spinoza
um he was like a Jewish philosopher
who's actually excommunicated one of the
very few Jews ever to be kicked out of
Judaism it was a much more of a
Christian Catholic thing yeah okay never
heard of that so he
thought about the universe and said
maybe God is not you know some
paraphrasing of course some bearded
person in the sky maybe God is just the
laws of physics themselves
[Music]
and and and Albert Einstein when
confronted with this similar question he
said if there is a God I would speak
about the universe then it would but it
was an if statement if there was a God I
would speak about it would be Spinoza's
God
where the laws of physics represent some
order to the universe right and that
order is would be this spinosian God
but what happens is you get people who
are deeply religious take Christians in
this example who would then say or even
Jews would say well if God has exists
then this is his holy book and these are
the rules and this is the part of the
penis I should have cut off on the
eighth day that I'm born and here's what
you should do you know all the rest of
these rules is not what Spinoza's God is
talking about that's right if you should
marry or what you you know yeah just
just look at what's in the Bible
that people are obeying
as part of the rest of the of the the
package
I don't want to call it baggage because
that implies but some people Delight in
it so I'll call the rest of the package
that comes with saying there's a supreme
deity
um
that's I mean this is fascinating so
even the Spinoza do you lean Spinoza any
lean I don't I don't are you being
tugged orbitally by the Spinosa I'm just
curious if it's something to look at
I'll look at it yeah and I can tell you
that
you know quantum physics doesn't marry
well with general relativity but the
physics the physics of the small general
relativity the physics of the large they
both work in their realms
but when the universe was small there's
a shotgun wedding between the two and we
still don't know how to put them
together maybe we're not smart enough
but the universe and the universe has a
chaos in it oh my gosh yeah there's
simple laws of physics but an asteroid
took out the dinosaurs and sixty percent
of all species of life on Earth to say
oh the universe is a Haven for life and
it's perfectly designed for life
when if I drop you butt naked 70 of
Earth's surface will have you dead
within 15 minutes
okay you'll freeze you'll get eaten
you'll starve you'll drown yeah you'll
drown yeah yeah yeah don't tell me this
universe is designed for human life do
you have a start oh go ahead
yeah I don't have I I
I'm too observant yes of everything that
the universe is for me it reminds me of
the people uh there's some tornado in
the Midwest and
um there's
you know and the News goes up to the
survivors of the tornado and the person
said oh
um God saved us today from this
and
and everyone just accepts that without
asking
um
who sent the tornado all right right no
you're easier to save you if there were
no tornado in the first place you're
right in my wheelhouse even though
obviously I I'm using some spiritual I'm
a spiritual person doctor uh doctor
father Greg Boyle says this thing he's
like these people send out the emails
they're like these are the people that
didn't go to work on 911 God saved them
and he's like what does that say about
the people that didn't go like why
aren't we asking that the kinds of
questions you're asking in your book why
aren't we looking at it objectively from
a zoomed out place and just go just look
at it that's why you know this isn't
gonna float your boat necessarily I
believe in a God that protects me from
nothing but sustains me and everything
but you could say that of a of Life of
like a life force it's not saving me
from a tornado but you know it's there
let me be neutral critique of that
um
many people feel the same way they just
call it something different yeah so if
you're comfortable referencing a deity
in that context and that brings you that
clarification and that Comfort uh in a
free country no one is going to take
that from you and no one should I won't
what are what brought you to those
spiritual encounters with the universe
so much of what you've been saying has
been giving me that awe that beautiful
feeling has it been in deep in study
looking at new data what is it that
gives you that Rapture that that feeling
the immensity of it all and how little
of it we know
we are so good at knowing what we know
that we have Quantified what we don't
know
so the dark matter I mentioned in Dark
Energy they're driving this universe
right now and it is 96 of what is
driving the universe the remaining four
percent is everything we know and love
and learned in biology chemistry physics
engineering everything that makes this
world what it is is four four percent of
the universe so astrophysicists are
inherently humble for that reason we
can't go around with our feet on the
desk extolling how that we're masters of
our no it's like my gosh and every day
if something new happens like who
ordered that let's find that out all
right who ordered black holes who
ordered you know the Big Bang who are
the where we're stumped and delighted
every day yes as astrophysicists and we
glean insights from that
to on earth like the molecules of your
body are traceable to the crucibles of
stars that gave their lives they
manufactured those elements billions of
years ago exploded scattered that
enrichment into gas clouds out of which
the next generation of stars and planets
was formed including the Sun and Earth
so you you were not simply alive in this
universe
the connectivity of your molecules
two stars
means the universe is alive within you
hmm and that borders on the spiritual
and I think it's one of the most
profound discoveries
gifted to Civilization by modern
astrophysics
that I Standing Ovation about
croissant drop that was a croissant so
beautiful but it goes back to that Carl
Sagan we are the eyes of the universe
looking at ourselves experiencing
ourselves carrying all of it but there's
a little bit of ego in that because it
assumes that we are smart enough to
actually
know everything worth knowing about the
universe right to say we are a way for
the universe to know itself well suppose
there's a billion times
deeper knowledge about the universe that
our primate brain cannot comprehend
right then that statement is hilarious I
agree harder species that's out there
that's what they just came out with that
idea that what our eyes are showing us
there's like a zero they said it was
like a all very close to zero chance
that what we're seeing is reality
because it would it would be filtering
out so much stuff that we're not even
said that close God I knew you were
going to ask me that yeah no no that's
no no you really so no no our
senses do work they give us some
fraction of objective reality that's in
front of us
often filtered through our biases yeah
but if I touch a round object I'm going
to say it's round you're going to touch
it you're not going to know this is a
cube we can agree on things that our
senses can identify right
but science
did not mature until it went beyond our
senses
until it realized no you don't see
everything you only see what we call
visible light but there's ultraviolet
and x-rays and gamma rays and radio
waves and and and all of that is also
lighting and you can't see it but I have
a chart recorder that can there are
other things like the polarization of
light this light Spectra gravitational
magnetic fields electromagnetic fields
all of this
science can detect about the natural
world
and establish objective truths we are no
longer dependent on human senses and
because when we were it is Rife with
bias as we've seen in this conversation
coming from I mean many many times one
last question I have to ask you this is
the third time you said you had one last
question is that true yeah
okay second time the the nothing one
these are these are the two questions I
was like I gotta ask and then and then
you're absolutely out of here
um have you heard the idea the the I
guess you'd call it a hypothesis that
reality is a shared Hallucination is
that that was a TED Talk that got a lot
of traction
uh they're philosophers that like going
there yeah and
um
it depends on what you mean by that
because
the methods and tools of science are
exquisitely tuned to establish an
objective reality
so the objective reality leads to a
quote I've been quoted on this it's on a
bumper sticker even the good thing about
science is that it's true whether or not
you believe in it so a shared
what's the term you use hallucination
hallucination
would not
necessarily be the same hallucination
for every person we all have very
different brain wirings we grew up in
different places we have different
awarenesses
so to now say with all the different
awarenesses and imaginations and biases
that we all have somehow we all agree on
a on a hallucinated reality I don't see
evidence of that I can say that we can
all eat different hallucinogens but if
we if we apply the same apparatus to a
thing in front of us
and the apparatus identifies the same
elements and features like a mass
spectrometer for example then it didn't
matter that you were tripping yeah yeah
yeah
I'm just not people like I mean it's fun
to talk about and think about but I
don't let them continue to do it but the
rest of us are actually discovering
objective reality out here
well they're arguing about whether or
not it's real right yeah no I am I'll
concede that by the way people wait
Einstein discovers equals mc squared we
weaponize uranium and plutonium build
two bombs drop it over Nagasaki and
Hiroshima in a war
killing at 40 000 people and you're
gonna say well this is a shared
hallucination yeah yeah what a stranger
what a strange choice right right
I'm not going there
I hear that do you do you see a a star
Trekkie future where we find world peace
and food synthesizers and we go out
there do you think human beings I see
One path of world of world of lesser
conflict and that is the universe
basically has unlimited natural
resources unlike Earth which has limited
natural resources so if we turn the
solar system into our backyard then
in principle could remove
an entire category of armed conflict
from the future history of civilization
which is resources War over access to
limited resources yeah well we might
still fight over what God you worship
yeah I still fight over what you know
how reflective your skin is to somebody
right right you might still fight over
what side of a line in the Sands you're
born on or what gods you worse at God or
Gods you worship or don't worship yeah I
still fight over that we talk we talk
about that where's the where's the
wealth with water or right or
we talk about that all the time if white
take white supremacy to its natural
conclusion give them what they want it's
only white people how long before
they're finding it you know more lines
in the sand to be like well you are
left-handed or you have already done
that yeah what do you think what
the the
Protestants yes Catholics killing each
other yes Ireland was right these are
two white people yes same shades of
white people yes in the same
killing each other for how what like
what the really
after I saw that I said look how black
people for no reason the white people
for that reason oh Europe was basically
white people killing white people yes it
had nothing to do with black or brown
people right gay people or yeah
somewhere yeah somewhere loaded up in
the in the in the Paddy and the you know
in the concentration camps but the
organized battle between France and
Italy and Germany and and and that in
England okay yeah white people and okay
throw in some some Japanese but that was
entirely in the Pacific Theater right
you know Japanese people fighting in
Europe okay right so yeah
white people really good at killing
people for any reason
I'm sorry for my I'm getting like you
and Sam Kinison you pull you I was calm
and peaceful at the beginning of this
conversation would we have video proof
of that yeah thank you
um this is those are my we're done with
my questions you've been so generous
I've I'll never forget this conversation
you're you're a delight and a gift and
I'm so happy I got to talk with you and
I hope to see you in person one day uh
this is the last question that everybody
gets so if I didn't ask you to go why
didn't Neil get the question can you
tell me a time in your life when you
laughed
so hard you hurt you tears streaming
down your face your belly aches maybe
you were a kid maybe somebody fell maybe
somebody farted that's often what the
answer is
um I would say one of the hardest times
I laughed
was
in the final scene
of it's a mad mad mad mad world and I
saw that I'm old enough to have seen it
in real in a theater in real time they
re-released it for its like 50th
Anniversary or six but I saw it when it
first came out in the 1960s wow and
Ethel Merman is in it who's just
screaming at everyone the entire movie
got her Ethel Merman voice and and she's
just annoying to everybody and but she's
not mean
she just wants what's best for you know
but still you you were done listening to
her okay at the end of the movie all the
main characters a big caper it's a caper
you don't remember the movie it was a
caper the chase scenes everybody in the
movie ended up in the hospital on some
kind of Gurney you know uh these all the
men okay who were chasing this
this
uh this treasure that was buried in this
park
in California okay that was hidden by a
by a criminal who stole the money from a
bank and it's a long story it's not even
worth retelling other than this last
scene okay they're all there up back I
don't they still do this everyone is in
a full cast up to their neck with legs
and this and there's a whole room of
them okay and they're all oh I'm hurt I
can't
um
and then Ethel Merman and her crew comes
in and starts yelling at them saying why
did you do this and one of the guys had
finished eating a banana
and just toss the banana peel and you're
not even paying attention he did it but
you're not noticing it she steps on the
banana peel
completely up ends lands on her ass and
all these moaning men just start
laughing and and and you know whatever
pain they were in didn't matter anymore
because oh they were just done all the
casts were just jiggling up and down and
I was eight or something and I laughed
so hard
because
we were done with her and that's how
they took her out and that was just and
when comedy transcends pain it's one of
the greatest
that was it that's it they were all just
in they were in pain and it didn't
matter yeah yeah because she had it
coming that's all that's that's the best
no one intentionally heard her right
because that would not be right no no
well that look I'm not even trying to
force this the the the signs of matter
like when when Abbott and Costello are
moving a piano up the stairs everyone
can get on board because we all know
that thing's heavier than they are it's
like comedy for everyone yeah physics is
comedy for everyone
right it's just simple physics at that
point yeah that's right and a banana is
slippery and uh there's and she falls
down because of gravity
you know thank you so much for taking
this time what a treat you are we have
the guests say uh the catchphrase at the
end it's just how we say goodbye it's
gonna be fun for me to hear it if you're
gonna say it it's just keep it crispy
would you grace us with a keep it crispy
this is Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist
and in life and in the universe it is
always best to keep it crispy
okay
what a thrill thank you so much you you
were on wait wait let me add let me add
a sentence go ahead
you know deep down that's true
you reach for the crispy french fry not
the Soggy one you reach for the crispy
potato chip not the one that's been out
in the humidity at the picnic
crispy wins every time every time you
know this
foreign
Neil deGrasse Tyson signing out yes all
right
[Music]